l'Union européenne soutiendra l'Ukraine
aussi longtemps que nécessaire promesse
d'eau sous la forme d'arlayenne la
présidente de la commission était à Kiev
pour une rencontre avec volo
diverselenski dont le pays est
formellement candidat a lieu depuis juin
États-Unis
au palais présidentiel de Kiev volodi
mirzelinski lui a réservé un accueil
chaleureux
accolade des grands sourires le chef de
guerre et la présidente de la Commission
européenne affiche leur unité pour
soulage anderleyen reçoit même un prix
des mains du dirigeant ukrainien pour
son soutien à la souveraineté et à
l'intégrité territoriale de l'Ukraine
nous remettons le prix Yaroslav Moudry à
Ursula vanderleyen présidente de la
Commission européenne la forme est
soignée mais Ursula vont dire les hyène
c'est qu'elle est attendue sur un point
en particulier l'adhésion de l'Ukraine à
l'Union européenne les 27 ont entériné
en juin dernier la candidature de Kiev
un processus long mais qui serait dans
la bonne voie
le processus d'adhésion est bien en
cours en parallèle nous nous sommes mis
d'accord sur le fait que nous devions
travailler le plus possible pour faire
en sorte que l'Ukraine est plus
d'entreprises davantage de revenus c'est
ainsi que l'Ukraine aura la possibilité
d'accéder de manière transparente au
marché commun européen
mais en attendant cette possible
adhésion l'Ukraine a surtout besoin d'un
soutien financier estimé par le
gouvernement à 5 milliards de dollars
par mois et d'une aide militaire plus
conséquente notre sécurité est dépend de
notre défense aérienne nous comprenons
tous l'importance des systèmes aériens
de défense mais je ne sais pas avec
exactitude comment résoudre ce problème
rapidement c'est notre priorité absolue
sur le front dans le nord-est du pays la
contre-offensive ukrainienne lancé début
septembre a permis aux forces armées de
reprendre russe la quasi-totalité de la
région de Raki